buon salve a tutti i ragazzi benvenuti
questo video sono pari j siamo ritornati
murray senso animati che teoricamente
dovrei trovare un modo per passare quel
ponte lì perché ovviamente qualcuno visi
minchia gli ingranaggi e non si muove
vabbè vedi che c'è un pezzo o tanky ho
trovato dentro la tenda c'era un pezzo
del ponte nella tenda beh ovvio c'è
anche uno sgabello me lo porto
vabbè lo sgabello era pesante ma
l'importante è che ci sia eccolo lì
penso di dover trovare ingranaggio che
vedo come abbasso il ponte come se fosse
un conto in lego cegliolo non mi fanno
fatica le braccia incredibile va beh
l'udc ha fatto
game to the cake passare per forza nelle
caverne per tornare a casa mattio però
che figata
se conte scampagnate cifra che bello
ragazzi mi sembra di giocare a skyrim a
questo punto madonna sembra ormai
arrivati ditemi se non sembra sky
mandatemi una spada ed è skyrim ecco la
casa mia la vedo dio casa mia dove come
l'ha raggiunta possa superare il ponte
così hanno aspetta c'è il ponte il fiume
volevo dire che non so come va bene è di
voto
esatto chissenefrega si no il tipo sta
impazzendo rega pronto ma c'è il
poliziotto si starà facendo mia moglie
come minimo per o meno male niente bad
news troppo dietro per forza
eccoci
signore pensavo giorni ok quindi a dover
andare a trovare devo andare a trovare
il tc però non ci passo dalla finestra
perché faccio schifo
lui ci passava invece tihomir o un'altra
casa figure mi mancava sta roba
ma che ci faccio questo sempre questo
paese frazione è andato pure in una casa
che non c'entra niente
bisogna una chiave the tower questa
seconda no non mi far salire fino a su
mamma mia quanto vi odio siamo gli fai
vedere che diavolo stai facendo cioè
faide che sono segnali veri non
nascondendo qualcosa sicuramente sta
nascondendo non si capisce però poi però
è però figo una mannaia stanno scalando
una mannaia questa io lo terrei non si
sa mai il suo gioco a posso sono un
genio non l'ho trovato mica per caso
ragazzi sono io che sono intelligente
c'e la chiave la chiave del cancellino
di prima ok che ben questo caos devo
sempre se questa roba da dove entrare
fammi entrare innanzi tutto ok
e adesso adesso cento per cento
eccolo
è entrato dentro che non ha idea di che
cosa ci sia padella sui medici però non
vanno il lavoro quel giorno in armonia
non lo so però è bello vivere in caso
tuo amico mio
non so cosa ci sta facendo gente morta
intorno a casa tua però fa più schifo il
posto dove è scelto di vivere ciò per
otto porca vacca venire lo sapevo che
switch al passato ogni 4 secondi porco
demonio io ero tutto convinto siamo
tornati ragazzi trovati in testing
allarme perché quando c'è il passaggio è
figo bello la miniera momento esistano
della bocca dell'oscurità beh allegro
713 numeri romani cosa significano i
ragazzi sono dentro delle mie rincari a
ecco vedi i numeri romani sono
contrassegnano e button che è bordello
dove devo andare
andiamo in giro vado prima tanto non so
cosa me ne frega di la mappa dove devo
andare non lo so vado in giro a caso
alla volta dell'oscurità non è che devo
seguire un percorso quindi devo andare a
713 devo fare il giro che potrebbe
essere anche così 613
[Musica]
stai tranquillo ho capito cosa devo fare
io devi solo seguire quello che li vedi
che è diventato verde perché è giusto
adesso tipo un stai zitto
esci da una parte ti riportata un'altra
ogni 66 l'ho già fatto poi c'è uno che
dovrebbe essere di qua corretto so cosa
devo fare smettila di lamentarti di 4
secondi
uno è adesso uno equano sono entrate
devo uscire devo andare di qua dritto 1
e adesso esco di qua e dovrei ritornare
dove lo prima perché un labirinto no
esatto adesso devo entrare nel 36 zitto
stai zitto eccolo e chao phraya che fa
sì vorrei aver fatto è scorretto eccolo
meno due veri che si riesce ad avanzare
nella miniera per via dei big mi
fighissimo che belle chiusure moderne
collettore della retina è presente
devono seguire giorno solo che ve li
prendi la pressione compreso aveva preso
un bellissimo non ci credo se si gira mi
ami
porca vacca che scelta stupida
ok è là dentro che deve entrare non so
come ma in qualche modo mi stanno
proseguendo
parola poi smette di camperare nel punto
dove devo andare io poi andare in
un'altra altro corso porca vacca un'ora
e mezza di ok
qua ci dovrei trovare delle cose aiuto
ecco dov'è ecco ok allora 97 vale social
79 78 978 97 89 78 zitto zitto zitto
figurano vestito niente 978 allora 9 ok
7 ok sinistra
la statua venne panel celo celo celo
celo celo celo celo non corri corri
corri corri frega niente frega niente se
vai dai 9 questo è il set
questo lotto mino 9 qua ra qua mi
ricordo cosa sono stupido io lo stupido
si sono stupido frega niente se c'è
gente stile di vita sta frase abbia
finito queste cagate delle miniere basta
lay out of the main dove vorrebbero
entrare 8 ore belushi
ok servirà qualcosa sta cosa che ho
fatto anche in penombra dovevi fare
stack agata qua anche in out la scritta
devi fare staccare al traguardo che ci
pensa dalla miniera
come mai un gioco horror ci sono sempre
le miniere ragazzi giannone miniere di
così horror ma devo prendere il carrello
tiro
carrellino mio devo uscire col carrello
devo salirci su stappare o cosa devo
fare
ma basta che mi sfondi quella roba lino
ecco come in out la strada comunale
precisa perfetto tanto lo guarda dopo
tutto quello che è successo mi stupisco
pd intanto ci sono quegli affari in giro
occhio eccolo giorno a noi morto a posto
ma come ancora vivo a li batte ancora il
cuore però rimaniamo nel semi di firenze
e la madonna e gobbi e impalato sono
vivo ho fatto un volo di otto chilometri
sono come se come se niente volta
correnti saving ad effetti quindi è una
boxe fight va bene una volta nella mia
cosa può fare a
devo chiudere le porte scala devo
capirlo scappa ward cavalca dove la
madonna perché le boss fight mette becco
tutte io ma niente sono vivo marco
demonio quanto ho fatto bene suo gioco
però allora semi dovevate far combattere
contro freezer me lo dici a te prima
cotta per il combattere contro freezer
si faceva una ram e ne faceva una
ragione basta jesus fatto non pensare in
fretta in sé comuniste situazioni non è
mai nemica paglia porco demonio porco
porco demonia sono saltato ma ho
sbagliato mi che volevo farlo tutto
senza mai morire alberto tasto porca
vacca non mi fa ripartire a 0 dai in
modo all'inizio delle miniere dal piano
1 peccato che ho sbagliato tasto se lo
fosse stato per quel avrei fatto una
ragni credimi la croce aiuto eccoci
azzeccato
no ma posso annunciarvi più guai
pezzente schifoso torna su una mac
esplodi alzate le mani al cielo
ragazzini lancio oggi in chi dava
[Musica]
agli è ritornato nel suo corpo
o
figo nevica
mannaggia alla miseria non è capito il
senso di vista cagata per ok bonus cuore
perché la sua debolezza va bene ti
colpiscono vai tranquillo
intanto spara alto e gelide cose quando
sono protetto e più o meno
xpa kat luc occhio occhio che cosa
lodevole sono debole sono debole fisso
notevole ho capito mi è passato nel
mentre che mi colpiva cosa devo fare
sono protetto adesso correre con un
puledro vai strappa le ro col piccone
devi farlo anche prima se non so se
ferita
no la mano c'è il brutto che sei ma
basta basta lanciarmi contro le cose
castillo è successo è staccata una trave
ehi ma basta togli timori una picconata
nel cuore ancora vivo de meno male che
c'è sempre un cristiano che mi salvarmi
sempre lui da giorno grazie gentile ma
dopo fratellino ti dava fastidio è
arrivato papa a ristabilire l'ordine
vabbè
cosa stai butti già colonna butta giù
ruota giu ma si picca di un calcio la
colonna di destra cola giorno
c
va bene
[Applauso]
ma puoi fare le cose anche cattive ma
stai calma calma senza cattiveria
giochiamo a calcio vado in porta
addirittura di mortaio
beh comunque allegro finale cioè finale
di chapter allegro chuter nine ho
battuto un boss sono forte e fiero di me
soprattutto va beh allegri allegri a
parte facciamo che continuano le
prossime episodio va spero che gli sia
piaciuto iscritte al canale credo che il
prossimo sarà l'ultimo immagino poi nodo
però penso di si schiaccia da
campanellina così rimanete aggiornati
quando esce anche l'ultimo episodio e vi
arriva la notifica e noi come sempre ci
vediamo ragazzi a un prossimo video
bella ragazza
[Musica]